this meme came up earlier this week it
went viral on
the internet it's from women on top
and it had two pictures it says my mom
at age 31
and me at age 31 and my mom at age 31
she's standing there she looks like
she's
in the 80s or something and she's got
these two kids and she's smiling and
she's hugging your kids
then me at age 31 it's a gal wearing
tights
with a roller bag and a
probably expensive purse here a chanel
purse and then a glass of champagne okay
and so you read then you say oh gosh
okay is this saying that this poor woman
is just not living as fulfilling a life
as her mother did that's kind of sad
but then there was a another image that
went with it
this is a picture of a woman and a guy
and a kid
obviously they're married they have this
kid it says an established and complete
woman with her family
and then there's a picture of a woman
wearing a sort of low-cut top
eating pizza sitting on a table with
also with a glass of champagne this
woman
really likes champagne i don't know i
don't know why all times of day walking
through the airport this lady needs to
booze up who knows why
and it says also an established and
complete
woman now i realize the point of this
they're saying look
any of your choices are not only fine
and acceptable
but they are equally conducive to human
flourishing there's nothing
intrinsically good about having kids or
settling down or getting married or
having a family
that is exactly as
good and purposeful and productive as
sitting and drinking champagne and cold
pizza or
or drinking champagne with expensive
luggage walking through an airport
not everybody gets to be to get married
not everybody it is a privilege it's a
nice thing some people are
called to other other things some people
are called to celibacy some people are
called
to religious life some people are called
to be married
not everyone gets to have a kid some
people suffer from infertility
some people maybe you can adopt a kid
but not everyone gets that kids are a
blessing right
however it is good to be married
it is better to be married and settle
down than it is to just pursue your own
appetites and drink champagne all day
long
all the way through your whole life it
is good
to have kids some people don't get to
have kids
we all suffer but it is good it is
better to have kids
than to choose not to have kids because
you want to pursue your own appetites
and just do whatever you want all the
time
someone tweeted this out the other day
they said why did people want to get
married and have kids when you could
do drugs in foreign countries i assume a
comedian but
i think there was a lot of earnestness
in what she was saying for a lot of
millennials
we need to have a standard and i think
conservatives need
to stop this kind of nonsense there are
a lot of conservatives who would say
that yeah just do whatever you want
do whatever you want you do you i who am
i to judge i can't no
that that's a dereliction of duty in a
dereliction of leadership and it's
making people miserable
and the reason by the way that these
these images work
is because it says me at age 31 and
when you're in your 30s you're still
like having fun and you're young and you
can do whatever you want
but these things have effects later on
in life and if you're
still boozing and just waking up with
bottles of champagne at age 61
maybe something's gone a little wrong
your partying day should be over at that
point
you should settle yourself a little bit
more and train your habits
and it's it's not not quite as glamorous
at that point
and this is lying to women in particular
and women have become
more miserable both in relative to men
and in absolute terms
as measured by any social scientific
survey since the 1970s
take social science with a grain of salt
but but all of them show it
and why is that it's because of these
sorts of lies of feminism and
conservatives i think have abandoned
them too
and conservatives because we just think
it's easier to throw up our hands and
say well who am i to judge i don't you
know whatever that's fine you do you
no it's not true that kind of attitude
toward life will make you miserable
never too late to throw that attitude
out but you absolutely
should i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts